but if you decide to I'll ride in this
life with you I won't let go till the
end
Lady Gaga makes a last-minute decision
to sing hold my hand at the 95th Academy
Awards on Sunday after initially
declining to perform
I'll be right
home
well the singer hit the stage for a
stripped down rendition of the
oscar-nominated song from Top Gun
Maverick rocking a French braid very
little makeup a black T-shirt and jeans
and kicked off the moment with a sweet
message for the audience you might find
that
you can be your own hero even if you
feel broken inside
it was initially reported that Gaga was
skipping the award show due to her
filming schedule for her upcoming flick
Joker Foley Adu the sequel to 2019's
Joker started production at the end of
2022. Gaga will play Harley Quinn
alongside Joaquin Phoenix who returns as
the Batman villain Margot Robbie
previously portrayed Harley on the big
screen and says Lady Gaga has her seal
of approval I think she's gonna do an
amazing job I'm so excited it's all I
could have ever hoped for Harley was
that she would become one of those
characters that kind of like Batman or
Hamlet gets handed from character you
know acted actor everyone gets a go at
playing them so I feel like it's just
credit to her as a character that you
know people want to see her in multiple
iterations I'm excited as for Gaga's
last minute change of heart a source
tells E.T she really wanted to perform
and genuinely just changed her mind and
she didn't disappoint in fact mother
monster received a standing Innovation
from the crowd the truth is I'm just
happy to be here in the presence of such
incredible artists I mean so much talent
in this room I can't believe that I'm
here and I'm so very happy before hold
my hand from Top Gun Maverick she was
nominated in 2016 for till it happens to
you from the hunting ground
and be strong and again in 2019 for
shallow from A Star is Born which landed
the singer her first Oscar win
[Music]
all it takes is to believe in yourself
and I just hope that people all over the
world tonight know that if you believe
in you and you love yourself and you put
your mind to it you can do anything and
while Gaga didn't take home Oscar gold
on Sunday an honor that went to rrr's
not to not to it's safe to say her
performance was a winner
foreign